una carrera contra un nuevo brote la
viruela del mono ya es una emergencia
sanitaria pública para el gobierno
federal de eeuu
la medida libera presupuestos de
emergencia permite la reorganización de
personal médico y da más acceso al
ejecutivo central sobre las personas
contagiadas y vacunadas el objetivo
contener el virus antes de que sea
endémico
behring estamos redoblando los esfuerzos
y asegurándonos que estamos cumpliendo
con el país y con lo que la gente
necesita en webkit poned la decisión de
la administración de joe biden de
declarar el brote como una emergencia
sanitaria llegará después de que la
organización mundial de la salud
emitiera su alerta global la unión
americana ha distribuido 11 millones de
dosis de la vacuna contra esta viruela
pero hay clínicas en nueva york y san
francisco que solamente han podido
aplicar una de las dos dosis del
antídoto por falta de suministros al
respecto el new york times reportó que
el gobierno estadounidense no solicitó
de manera temprana a la fabricante
bavaria nordic el embotellado de lotes
de vacunas que ya eran de su propiedad y
en medio de esta polémica el gobernador
de florida por un distante quien se
muestra como un posible candidato
presidencial republicano cargo contra
las recomendaciones sanitarias del
gobierno contra el virus
james sé que estoy tan cansado de los
políticos y vimos esto con el co beat
intentan sembrar terror en la población
hay gente que nos está llamando madres
que están preocupadas por si sus hijos
se pueden contagiar en el colegio no
vamos a regresar a folchi en los 80
cuando él le intentaba decir a las
familias que iban a contraer vih por ver
la televisión concebir y geller estados
demócratas como nueva york california
illinois ya habían emitido su emergencia
sanitaria la semana pasada alrededor de
7000 estadounidenses han sido infectados
con la viruela del mono la cual presenta
casos actuales en 70 países del mundo el
virus produce fiebre y sarpullidos entre
otros síntomas se contagia
principalmente con el contacto y
presenta una mortalidad de en torno al 1
por ciento